هذه
الوقت في المستقبل
[موسيقى]
محرم بك نسميه عنايت واحد.
لا تريد استخدام جهاز
بهاتفه
كنت تعطي أراد أن يتحدث رمح الرمح
كنت أرغب في الاستسلام أصر
أصر استخدامنا للهاتف على ذلك
لم نرغب في استخدام هاتف المنزل الذي كنا عليه
ثم استخدم هاتفه الخاص
مكالمة هاتفية أثناء البث.
لقد قدمنا ​​أيضا منطقتنا
لقد أعددنا بالفعل
لتسليم هذا الهاتف الذي نحن عليه
ذهبت أثناء البث لكنه قبيح
وقع الهجوم عليّ مثلي
أحاول أن يتم قبولي
أجل
حسنًا ، تحدثت السيدة فاطمة إلى مديرنا الإقليمي.
ذلك وبعد الحدث بجوهره الذي نراه
بعد فترة وجيزة ، أنا ونحن أيضًا
لا تتحدث بعد رحيلهم
صرخ القطب بالفعل في موظفيه
اتصل بي كيف حال الناس هكذا؟
ما تفعله هو خمس وأربعون دقيقة
سأبحث عن شخص ما ليوجهني
قال أنك فعلت
[موسيقى]
لكن
نظرت في المستقبل
اشترك